مرحبا انا سفيان ثابت لنتابع معا ابرز
اخبار الاسبوع الماضي باجازه وضمن ابرز
الاحداث الضفه الغربيه تشهد اسبوعا عصيبا
فاجنر تساعد ضد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وانفجار غواصه تيتان واخبار اخرى لنتابعها
معا
نبدا نشرتنا من الضفه الغربيه التي شهدت
احداثا كبيره وذلك بعد اقتحام اسرائيلي
لمخيم جنين استخدمت فيه المروحيات للمره
الاولى منذ اكثر من 20 عاما اسفر عن
استشهاد خمسه فلسطينيين بينهم طفله وجيش
الاحتلال اعلن سحب 5 اليات عسكريه من
اطراف المخيم اعطبتها الفصائل الفلسطينيه
وبعد يوم من الاقتحام اقدم شبان فلسطينيين
على هجوم مسلح اوقع اربعه اسرائيليين في
مستوطنه علي بالضفه وصفته حماس والتي تبنت
العمليه بانه رد على جرائم الاحتلال في
جنين واعلنت لاحقا استشهاد المنفذين
الاحداث لم تتوقف هنا فقد دعاش اهالي بلده
ترمس عيه بالضفه ساعات عصيبه بعد اقتحامها
من قبل المستوطنين
لنسال مراسلنا سمير ابو شماله عما حدث
هناك
مرحبا سمير ماذا حدث اذا في ترمس
نعم سفيان ما جرى في بلده بطرسعيه الشمالي
رام الله هو اشبه ما يكون بما جرى في بلده
حواره جنوبي نابلس قبل نحو خمسه اشهر
عشرات من المستوطنين المتطرفين اقتحموا
البلده من عده محاور وايضا قاموا باحراق
العشرات من المنازل والمركبات التابعه
للمواطنين الفلسطينيين وذلك تحت اعين
وحمايه من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيليه الذي
هو بدوره ايضا صار الى قمع المواطنين
الفلسطينيين الذين خرعوا لنجده اقربائهم
وجيرانهم وقد استخدم اطلق الرصاص واستخدم
قنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع و ادى ذلك الى
استشهاد الشاب عمر جباره واصابه اربعه
اخرين في بجروح
شكرا سمير الى الشارع الروسيه الان والذي
يشهد احداثا ساخنه اذ اتهم قائد مجموعه
فاغنر العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
الدفاع الروسيه بقصف معسكرات مقاتليها
متواعدا بالانتقام من قياده الجيش الروسي
وشنقي وزير الدفاع في ساحه الحمراء واعلن
لاحقا سيطره مقاتليه على كل المنشات
العسكريه في روستوف مع قليل قياده العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا كما نقلت رويترز عن
السلطات الروسيه ان مقاتلي فاجنر سيطر على
جميع المنشات العسكريه في مقاطعه فرونيج
جنوب موسكو بدوره ترامب الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الذين دعوا الى التمرد
المسلح بالخيانه متوعدا بمحاسبتهم وطالبهم
بالتراجع عن المشاركه بما وصفها بالاعمال
الاجراميه نذهب الى امريكا وتطورات فقدان
غواصه تي اذا توقفت اعمال البحث عن
الغواصه في شمال المحيط الاطلسي قرب حطام
تيتانيك باعلان الشركه المشغله تعرضها الى
انفجار داخلي اودى بحياه ركابها الخمسه
كما اكد خفر السواحل الامريكيه انه تم
تحديد موقع حطام الغواصه بواسطه مركبه
يتحكم فيها عن بعد بالقرب من حطام سفينه
تايتنك الحادثه اثار التساؤلات في الصحف
والمجتمعات الغربيه عن الفرق بين الجهود
التي بذلت للعثور على الغواصه وبين
الاستجابه لنداء مركب على متنه نحو 750
لاجئا بينهم اطفال غرقا امام سواحل
اليونان الاسبوع الماضي شاركونا ارائكم في
التعليقات لماذا هبت فرق دوليه للعثور على
الغواصه بينما لم تمد الايدي لسفينه طالب
اللجوء الى موضوع اخر حيث اجرى وزير
الخارجيه الام
زياره الى الصين هي الاولى من نوعها منذ
خمس سنوات التقى خلالها الرئيس الصيني
ووزير الخارجيه تشينج وبحث بلينكن ملفات
عده ابرزها قضيه اذا اكد التزام بلاده
بمبدا الصين الواحده واعرب عن امله في حل
قضيه مضيق تايوان سلميه كما اشار الى ان
هناك اتفاقا مع بيجين على الحاجه لاستقرار
العلاقات مع واشنطن بدوره اكد الرئيس
الصيني احراز تقدم في المحادثات معلنا
التوصل لاتفاقات بشان عدد من القضايا وسرح
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بان علاقات
بلاده مع الصين تمضي في الطريق الصحيح
لكن ما دلالات هذه الزياره التي تاتي وسط
فطور في العلاقات بين البلدين لنسال
الكاتب الصحفي المختص في الشان الامريكي
محمد المنشاوي حول هذا الموضوع
مرحبا سيد محمد اذا هل ستطوح بهذه الزياره
فصول التوتر بين الجانبين لا اتصور سفيان
ان زياره الوزير بلينكن الى الصين استنجح
في ردمه الخلافات بين الولايات المتحده
والصين نحن لسنا امام ازمه علاقات ثنائيه
بين دولتان عاديتين نحن امام
نظام عالمي يعد تشكيله في هذه الاثناء
الدوله مهيمنه على النظام العالمي منذ
اكثر من نصف القرن ودوله صاعده تهدد
وتتحدى هذه الهيمنه بدايه في نطاقها
الاقليمي في مضيق تايوان او في بحر الصين
الجنوبي وراينا هناك حربا تجاريه تحاول ان
تغلف هذه الصراعات الاستراتيجيه بين
الدولتين واعتاد ان بلنكن نجح في اركان
بزياره وهذا نجاح في حد ذاته ولقاء الرئيس
الصيني لكن هذه كانت محاوله
للسيطره على التنافس بينهما حتى لا تندلع
مناوشات عسكريه كما وجدناهم اقترب من هذا
السيناريو في بحر الصين الجنوبي خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره واعتقد ان ما حدث هو
تهدئه في العلاقات الى ان تنشب ازمه جديده
قريبا
شكرا لك سيد محمد نذهب الان الى العاصمه
الفرنسيه حيث وداهمت الشرطه هناك المقر
الرئيسي للجنه المنظمه لاولمبياد باريس
2024 بعد دعوى حركها المدعي العام المالي
تتعلق بشبهات تضارب مصالح واختلاس امواله
والاستيلاء غير القانوني على الفوائد ضمن
تحقيق بدا عام 2017 بشان العقود التي
ابرمتها اللجنه للاولمبياد ثم اعقبه تحقيق
اخر العام الماضي تاتي هذه التطورات في
وقت يستعد فيه عمال خدموا في مواقع البناء
الخاصه بدوره الالعاب الاولمبيه لمقاضاه
شركات بناء كبرى تنفذ المشاريع بسبب ظروف
عملهم السيئه والتي حرمتهم من ادنى حقوقهم
ووضعتهم تحت الخطر وطره لان يقتنوا وسائل
حمايه بانفسهم على حد تعبيرهم
ومغردون تفاعلوا مع هذه التطورات التي
جاءت قبل نحو عام من افتتاح الحدث الرياضي
نرصد لكم بعضا من هذه
يقول عندما يتعلق الامر بفرنسا فان الجميع
يصمت على عكس ما حدث لقطر قبل ثمانيه اشهر
اما ان نفعل الاشياء بشكل صحيح ونعالج
جميع انواع الافلات من العقاب او ان نصمت
ونمضي قدما بينما قال نيكولاس بدوره ولان
الامر لا يتعلق ببلد مسلم لن يكون هناك
حملات مقاطعه من فريس الى مكه المكرمه حيث
يتوافد الحجاج من كل حدب وصوب الى هذه
البقعه المقدسه لاداء فريضه الحاج حيث
تبدا المناسك في وقت متاخر من يوم الاحد
ويتوقع ان يصل عدد الحجاج هذا الموسم الى
اكثر من مليوني حاج من اكثر من 160 دوله
نسال مراسلنا من هناك والى الدحدوح عن
الصوره عنده
اهلا بك وائل يعني لو تنقل لنا المشهد من
مكه المكرمه
سفيان المشهد بطبيعه الحال هو مشهد
العاطفي وجداني تعبدي سرياني صح التعبير
مشهد عجيب تفاصيل كثيره حقيقه لا يمكنك ان
تشاهدها او تحياها دون ان تصاب بالصدمه
والذهول لكن في ذات السياق يشكل كل هذه
التفاصيل لوحه فنيه عجيبه وغريبه ورائعه
وسرياليه كما قلنا الابيض بجوار الاسود
بجوار الاحمر المراه والرجل الطفل الكبير
الشيخ العجزه المرضى المسنين الاصحاء كلهم
يسخون في زحف واضح لهذه التلاوين الكثيره
باتجاه القبله التي يصلون نحوها وكلهم
ياملون في خشوع
ان ينالوا الجائز الكبرى جائزه الامر في
رحله
شكرا لك وائل بهذا نصل لنهايه هذه النشره
نلتقي بكم في ايجاز اخر الاسبوع المقبل
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]